with reaction senator Ted Cruz by the
way parently now is a nightly podcast
called verdict great constitutional
attorney you know it's interesting Alan
Dershowitz a liberal says you were one
of his best students ever at Harvard Law
School let's go over what I've just
discussed here the constitutionality of
this do you agree with my analysis and
then professor Dershowitz his analysis I
do I think professor Dershowitz his
argument that he presented to the Senate
was powerful it was compelling that the
Constitution requires high crimes or
misdemeanors that the test for
impeachment it's treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors and
then the House Democrats they haven't
alleged any crime whatsoever it utterly
fails the constitutional standard but
you know Sean I listen to your opening
monologue and and and the four and five
points that you made and they're right
but let me boil it down to one one point
that explains why the president is
innocent and he should be acquitted and
why he will be acquitted
quid pro quo doesn't matter it's a red
herring it doesn't matter if there was a
quid pro quo or not the reason is a
president is always justified and in
fact has a responsibility to investigate
credible evidence of corruption the
Democrats built their entire case on the
proposition that it was baseless and a
sham and phony to investigate corruption
to investigate burry smih and the
Biden's you've done a good job of
walking through the reality which is
there was a mountain of evidence now do
I know for a fact that Joe Biden was
corrupt no but there was more than
enough for the President to say hey we
ought to investigate it when this guy's
sons getting paid a million bucks a year
when he's bragging about forcing Ukraine
to fire the prosecutor that stinks and a
minimum should be investigated that in
and of itself
senator eliminates the Democrats case I
have been saying that it's the
president's role to faithfully execute
the laws of the land a Ukraine Court
political January 11 2017 they laid out
chapter and verse that Ukraine separate
and apart from the Russian and
appearance that did occur that they
interfered in our election could you do
us a favor get to the bottom of
we spent three years of the country
dealing with us number two okay Joe
Biden on tape you you're not getting the
billion until you fire the prosecutor
investigating my zero experience son
who's going to continue to get paid now
I'm not a lawyer Ted Cruz you are that
sounds like not only faithfully
executing but I think even Sean Hannity
could bring that before a jury and get a
conviction look IIIi think that's
exactly right if you look at the
Democrats argument and I will say the
Senate we've conducted a fair trial we
listen to the House Democrats for 22
hours we listen til practically our ears
bled we heard all the evidence all the
witness testimony every argument that
they made over and over and over again
you know they spent about half of that
time trying to prove that President
Trump wanted an investigation into Joe
Biden hundred Biden briefs but well you
know what you and I could have proved
that in 30 seconds because the president
is it said that on national television
repeatedly that is conceded yes Donald
Trump wanted the corruption or potential
corruption investigated that is a good
thing not a bad thing I'll tell you
something else that's ironic everything
they accused the president of and say
the president did wrong the Democrats
have done worse
so they accused the president of
withholding aid to Ukraine well you and
I both know that that Barack Obama
refused to give lethal aid to Ukraine
for his entire presidency Donald Trump
has given javelin missiles anti-tank
missiles
so if delaying aid to Ukraine is wrong
that Obama did it worse if investigating
a political rival is wrong
well then let's pause for a second
because Obama investigated a political
rival sent in spies sent in wiretap
unleash the FBI and DOJ and investigated
the Republican nominee so for the
Democrats it's worth asking them what
exactly are you saying the President did
wrong and which part of it has your
party not done ten things worse well
said senator and I'm gonna tell you
another thing
I think I'm thankful the president is
looking out for our money you're hanging
out with those same guys is your
predecessor that
not a good idea never mention the aid no
quid pro quo I want nothing and at the
end the four facts remain the same five
subsequent meetings high-profile wit
Solinsky aid never discussed senator
Cruz this needs to end and if your
colleagues on the Republican side don't
end it then I've got a problem with all
of them because they're useless to our
Constitution and the rule of law in my
opinion look I agree enough already move
on on Friday I'm gonna vote that we
don't need any more witnesses which
seventeen witnesses in the house we've
heard all the evidence the house
managers have failed I hope that that
motion passes it's closed all 47
Democrats are going to vote for more
witnesses because they want a fishing
expedition and we may get I hope we
don't but we might get four wobbly
Republicans stand with them you know you
mentioned it just a few minutes ago the
podcast I'm doing so I started it on the
first day of the trial and every day
when the trial is over I jump in a truck
head to the studio and record a podcast
that night first one I did at 2:46 in
the morning and I share my thoughts that
podcast went from being non-existent to
being the number one podcast in the
country the number one I got a ranked
podcast and and it's the verdict with
its verdict with Ted Cruz so it's we're
talking about the facts and law put it
on detail every night on my website
Hannity calm I want to hear it senator
if I'm allowed I got to check the laws